mit dem anstiftung zum aufruhr anlass
ist der sturm auf das kapitol vor gut
vier wochen die demokraten die wollen
seine rückkehr auf die politische bühne
verhindern die mehrheit der republikaner
die steht aber weiter zu donald trump
schließlich haben ihn ja 74 millionen
amerikaner gewählt impeachment gegen
trump comeback ausgeschlossen unser
thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen aus berlin guten
abend ich darf meine gäste vorstellen
professor christiane lemke ist bei uns
professorin für politikwissenschaft mit
schwerpunkt internationale beziehungen
an der universität hannover show guten
abend und ihre kirschbaum begrüße ich
herzlich amerikanischer freier
journalist er arbeitet unter anderem für
die los angeles times und zugeschaltet
aus frankfurt ist uns ralf freund er ist
vizepräsident und sprecher der
republicans abroad germany ist mitglied
der cdu und der republikanischen partei
der usa schönen guten abend herr freund
genannt und in washington begrüße ich
ganz herzlich kerstin klein
korrespondentin für das ard studio in
washington schönen guten abend frau
klein und dann sie direkt die frage
dieser tag diese diskussion jetzt im
senat die ja seit einigen stunden läuft
beschäftigt dass die amerikaner wirklich
oder sind das noch mehr die auswirkungen
vom super bowl und der start von joe
biden was ist wichtiger das ist
jedenfalls relativ schwierig an diesem
ereignis vorbeizukommen wenn man den
nachrichten fernsehen schaut das input
mit verfahren läuft auf allen
nachrichtenkanälen hier
ob die leute noch interessiert das ist
ein bisschen schwer zu sagen also die
emotionen waren sehr hoch nachdem
sechster januar und ich glaube sie sind
es auch immer noch in teilen aber es ist
wahrscheinlich auch auf manche bei
manchen schon gewisse müdigkeit es ist
das zweite pid verfahren trump ist jetzt
nicht mehr im amt und so wird es
wahrscheinlich wie so vieles hier vom
politischen standpunkt abhängen wie man
darauf guckt viele demokratische
anhänger werden ganz sicher der meinung
sein das ist nötig dass trump noch
einmal gepusht wird und viele
republikanische anhänger werden
wahrscheinlich sagen lasst es gut sein
der ist aus dem abend oder vielleicht
sogar der meinung sein er hat doch gar
nichts wirkliches getan also das
wahrscheinlich auch wieder eine
unterschiedliche einschätzungen
anhand des politischen standpunkten und
womit rechnet man denn heute abend was
denken sie also wie wird es jetzt
ablaufenden und wird es wirklich dann zu
einem amtsenthebungsverfahren also dem
zum nächsten schritt kommen es ist ja
alles ein bisschen kompliziert aus
deutscher sicht genau momente sind noch
die debatte darüber ob dieses verfahren
überhaupt zulässig ist ob es
verfassungsgemäß einen präsidenten in
einem amtsenthebungsverfahren zu
verurteilen der gar nicht mehr im amt
ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt diese debatte
läuft gerade da ist aber zu erwarten
dass das nachher positiv beschieden wird
dass diese debatte weiter geführt wird
dass sie es in between verfahren
weitergeführt weil die demokraten mit
der stimme der vize-präsidentin eine
mehrheit haben das heißt es wird zu
diesem impeachment verfahren kommen und
das wird sich ja noch die nächsten tage
sich hinziehen
vermutlich sogar in die nächste woche
noch ok der freund seit einigen stunden
läuft die diese debatte die fing auch
sehr emotional an mit einem film wo noch
mal die parallele entwicklung gezeigt
wurde an diesem 6 januar der ja so viele
aufgewühlt hat können sie verstehen dass
man sagt da muss der präsident zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden also ich
kann durchaus verstehen dass es dauert
animositäten gibt zum einen der
präsident ist ja nicht die ursache
dieses sturms gewesen der präsident
hatte diese diesen sturm tag ich mal
noch einmal befeuert aber die ursache
lag ja ganz woanders er hat sie nicht
organisiert es waren noch keine
vertreter der republikanischen partei
also das muss man sorgfältig miteinander
abwägen das andere was man sehen muss
man muss hier aufpassen dass wirklich
nur für gravierende dinge an impeachment
verfahren angeschoben wird dass es kein
politisches engagement verfahren ist
dass man das aus politischen taktischen
erwägungen macht das so ein bisschen
inflationär wird das heißt man sollte
wirklich zu sehen ist es denn wirklich
eine gravierende verfehlungen die
seinerzeit bei nixon
es gab noch nie einen präsidenten david
pietsch wurde entweder sie
zurückgetreten oder sie sind wie bei
clinton oder bei tram abgeschmettert
worden
dann muss man ganz vorsichtig sein ist
es denn wirklich fundamental
gerechtfertigt oder dient ist nur der
taktik ich glaube die werden meister im
nächsten tagen und wochen werden wir
jetzt dort sehr viel dazulernen und
aufmerksam beobachten müssen wie sich
die demokraten in ihrer argumentation
dann aufstellen werden was würden sie
denn sagen war es eine gravierende
verfehlungen von donald trump aufzurufen
zum kapitol zu gehen
also ich halte es absolut für eine
verfehlung frage ist ist das lang das
für einen pitch bend verfahren also ich
finde es unsäglich dass es passiert ist
durchaus ein schaden für die demokratie
aber lang das einatmen des amtes zu
entheben wo er doch gar nicht mehr im
amt ist und b passiert schon eine
politische aussage von mir gibt man dann
nicht besser trump
mehr aufmerksamkeit als ihnen gut tun
würde ist er dann nicht wieder in der
märtyrer position also das sind alles
dinge die demokraten beachten müssten
dass es das nicht ganz nicht ein
bumerang effekt einen gewissen trotz
effekten der bevölkerung erzeugen das
ist natürlich sehr spannend wie es
aufgenommen wird der kirschbaum wo ist
donald trump jetzt eigentlich und wie
schaut er dann wohl auf dieses verfahren
den job ist seit zwei wochen den freude
der hat keinen titel mehr da kein
facebook der äußert sich ganz selten nur
ab und zu ein statement das schon
untergetaucht
angeblich wusste dass ein bisschen aber
nicht wie vor einem jahr wo ständig
dazwischen gedrittelt hat job ist ruhig
geworden das ist ruhiger um ihn geworden
ja heißt dass er hat berater die ihm
auch dazu raten ruhig zu sein oder ist
es wirklich ein zeichen dass er sich
auch zurückziehen will aus der politik
das ist eine gute frage aber die erste
mannschaft die erste weg sein welt sind
weggegangen vor zwei wochen die tracks
antwortet ihnen selbst verteidigen der
neue mannschaft wer weiß was mit trump
jetzt ist aber dass eine ernsthafte
sache das ist wirklich eine ernsthafte
anklage jetzt vom haus das gekommen ist
die haben das ganz auf einen punkt
fokussiert das war nicht völlig vor und
während vor einem jahr dass das hat sehr
lange gedauert sondern die haben
wirklich auf ein thema konzentriert
haben diese wie sie gesagt haben diese
bewegende videobeweis zusammen gemacht
wie ein hollywood film dass man sieht
die emotionen wie die revidierte da in
ihrem gebäude angst hatten
wie diese protest leute da reingestürzt
in die guten leute umbringen die wollten
mich umbringen das ist das steckt noch
in den knochen man spürt dass man spürt
da schon mit dem leben und diese firmen
frau denke das ist das so eine aussage
ist natürlich extrem außergewöhnliche
situationen dieser sechste januar und
ist das dann auch gerechtfertigt zu
sagen und macht es sinn dieses verfahren
einzuleiten da er ja kein präsident mehr
ist da ja die tat die ihm vorgeworfen
wird aufruf zum aufstand liegt ja noch
in seiner amtszeit und insofern ist das
eine grundsätzliche frage kann der
präsident dafür zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden denn er war ja noch präsident das
verfahren im haus ist ja auch
eingeleitet worden als er noch im amt
war
und insofern ist die
verfassungsrechtliche absicherung dieses
verfahren
eigentlich gegeben und die
gegenargumentation der verteidiger von
donald trump steht eigentlich sehr
wackeligen füßen in dem punkt weil sonst
könnte ja jeder präsident in den letzten
wochen seiner amtszeit schlimme dinge
tun und kann dafür nicht mehr belangt
werden das kann ja nicht sein also das
ist auch nicht im sinn der verfassung
insofern ist das schon ganz richtig dass
er jetzt hier vor dem senat trump vor
dem senat auch rede und antwort stehen
muss also eher nicht persönlich aber
durch seine rechtsanwälte und die frage
ist wie werden sich die republikaner
verhaltet euch nochmal direkt an sie
herr freund was man braucht ja um das
wirklich dann durchzuziehen bräuchte man
ja eine zweidrittelmehrheit das heißt 17
republikaner müssten mit stimmen gibt es
eine chance dass es genügend
republikaner gibt die sagen so wie sie
es ja auch sagen es war eine gravierende
verfehlungen und da müssen wir jetzt
klar ein signal zu setzen
also man muss ich mal jetzt nach der
wahl die zusammensetzung der
republikanischen abgeordneten genauer
anschauen
dort haben viele christen einzug
gehalten vor allen dingen auch im
repräsentantenhaus auch die
innerparteilichen abstimmung also die
vorwahlen innerhalb der amerikanischen
partei haben überwiegend diejenigen die
sie stramm pisten nennen den vorzug beim
wähler erhalten gegenüber denen die sich
grand old party nennen so beispielsweise
wie eine wie ich beispielsweise das
heißt auch im senat war das ähnlich
gelagert auch leute die früher keine
freunde von jump wand erklärt die gegner
wie auch cruise beispielsweise sind
mittlerweile auch seine linie geschwenkt
es ist äußerst unwahrscheinlich dass ich
17 amerikaner finden aus einer gewissen
loyalität heraus aus einer gewissen
gemeinschaftsgefühl aber auch aus einer
gewissen stärke heraus wird man sich dem
nicht anschließen also dieses verfahren
ist meiner ansicht nach politisch
zumindest ist es tot die frage ist hat
es eine außenwirkung über die abstimmung
hinaus was denken sie da mehr ist
natürlich ein zeichen die demokratische
partei weiß natürlich genau sie wird
dieses verfahren nicht gewinnen aber wir
möchten ein zeichen setzen
sie möchten wehrhaft sein sie möchten
für für anstand und ordnung stehen sie
möchten damit identifiziert werden und
möchten ein bisschen mit dem finger auf
die lokal vor allem auf donald trump
zeigen aber auch etwas auf die
republikanische partei und möchten dort
auch in politische akzente setzen so
klein wie wird es bei den republikanern
aus ihrer sicht diskutiert ist das ist
das ein streit der der innerhalb der
partei sehr stark ist dass man die frage
ist bist du für oder gegen donald trump
ist das sowie die zentrale frage wo man
die man sich stellt ja das ist schon ein
ziemlich grundsätzlicher richtungsstreit
bei den republikanern
ja es gibt die drei hat trump anhänger
die mit ihm auf einer linie sind die
seine überzeugung teilen
und dann gibt es aber auch eine anzahl
von republikanern die auch mindestens
geschockt waren von dem was da passiert
sind sie harmonieren teilen eine
teilschuld bei donald trump sehen aber
es ist auch für die nicht so einfach
sich von donald trump loszusagen
sie haben es vorhin gesagt 74 millionen
menschen haben donald trump gewählt er
hat millionen von menschen mobilisiert
das ist seine treue bartz viele von
denen haben die republikaner wegen trump
gewählt und das ist natürlich jetzt
schwierig für republikanische
abgeordnete sich gegen tram zu stellen
da ist die sorge dass man die basis
verliert die eigene oder auch zb dass
deutschland es hat ja schon angekündigt
bei den zwischenwahlen im kommenden jahr
dann noch eigene gegenkandidaten
möglicherweise aufstellt gegen
vermeintliche verräter und die dann
somit um ihre posten bringt also da ist
ganz viel auch machtkalkül dahinter und
sorge um die eigene karriere und um die
eigene partei und deren wählbarkeit wenn
man trump zu hart angeht und damit die
trump anhänger verprellten aber hat sich
das geändert seit dem 6 januar sind also
haben sich leute noch mal auf die andere
seite sozusagen geschlagen danach das
prominenteste beispiel ist mitch
mcconnell der früher mehr frühere
mehrheitsführer im senat jetzige
minderheitenführer der hat nach der wahl
lange geschwiegen war ja auch jahrelang
ein tramp loyal ist hat sich sehr spät
dann da dazu durchgerungen zu sagen
jetzt ist es so joe biden ist
präsidentin wählen wir jetzt und der hat
ja nach dem 6 januar sehr klare worte
gefunden
aber das ist einer wenn er dann also und
dann hat jetzt muss über diese
abstimmung ob dieses verfahren überhaupt
rechtlich in ordnung ist auch dagegen
gestimmt bei dem ist zu vermuten dass er
nachher für eine verzahnung von trump
stimmen könnte aber das ist einer wir
hatten es eben schon es müssten 17 sein
und ich sehe nicht dass diese 17
zustande kommen also der ausgang dieses
verfahrens steht eigentlich jetzt schon
ziemlich fest ok der kirschbaum wie
mächtig ist donald trump noch für sie
ihre publikum partei oder wie wichtig ja
wie wichtig sei erstmal wie wichtig und
dann sprechen wir über die macht schon
spannend dass er noch so viele
unterstützer hat und wollen dass die
republikaner angst vor ihm haben aber
manche republikaner für die menschen
bekannt
insgesamt freut sich dass trotz
schwierigkeiten hat war diese
impeachment seine art keine chance
bereinigen das funk von der partei zu
bereinigen dass vor allem die kandidaten
dessen vier jahren präsident sein wollen
wie passt uns so von raska für diese
chance jetzt schon zu entfernen weil ein
ganzes stück expect von diese ganzen
verfahrens der senat kann auch abstimmen
ob schon disqualifiziert werden sein
könnte in vier jahren das ist auch ein
thema das ist dabei eine einfache
mehrheit und für viele republikaner ist
es wichtig zu sehen ob kommt vielleicht
wirklich für immer und ewig gesperrt
werden könnte
von federal office und das ist auch ein
wichtiger schritt aber job hat nach wie
vor viele viele macht in der partei aber
wir werden sehen wie lange das anhält
also es könnte durchaus im interesse der
republikaner seien das stammt eben dass
kein weiteres politisches mandat nehmen
kann aber andererseits ist er ja eine
garantie ein garant dafür dass viele die
republikaner wählen
ja das ist das problem mit schon bis es
fertig ohne ende mit dem aber natürlich
es gibt viele die die wollen dass die
partei jetzt befreit werden von von tom
und diese
was am sechsten januar passiert es hat
viele republikaner auch geschockt ja bis
bis 50 januar waren die alle haarig
sieht aber danach hat man diese
zwischentöne mehr gehört und man sieht
dass es nicht wie zum beispiel die dritt
maxtax republikaner im kongress die
tochter von dem vize präsident hat auch
gegen short gewährt im haus und dafür
hat sie jetzt große ärger zu hause in
wyoming man sieht dass diese diese
kräfte in der republikanischen partei
immer noch so brüdern und manche trauen
sich nicht aus der deckung aber und
diejenigen die aus der deckung
zuerst kriegen dann ärger aber es ist
ein partei die wirklich voll von
spannungen sehr frau lemke was geht es
da weiter in der republikanischen partei
die partei so wenn es da auch eine
spaltung gibt es das land ist gespalten
und diese partei dann auch also wie kann
man das hinkriegen dass diese partei
hier nach vorne kommen also die
republikanische partei hat ein sehr
großes problem denn sie hat sich
eigentlich während der vier jahre
amtszeit von donald trump ihm völlig
untergeordnet und die noch kritisch
waren die moderaten republikaner sind an
den rand gedrängt worden sind auch nicht
mehr repräsentiert und das ist für die
große alte partei die sich ja selber
nennen
ein großes problem dass man die
liberalismus aufgegeben hat dass man den
freien handel aufgegeben hat dass man
zur einwanderungsdebatte eigentlich gar
nichts neues mehr beitragen kann also
alles große probleme vor denen die
gesellschaft steht dafür haben die
republikaner keine antwort wie kann ja
sind ja sehr erfolgreich gewesen nein
sie sind nicht erfolgreich gewesen denn
sie haben den senat verloren
sie haben im abgeordnetenhaus eine
mehrheit sie haben das weiße haus
verloren
also sie haben mit ihrer strategie in
allen drei branchen wenn sie so wollen
der regierung verloren
sie haben jetzt nur im obersten
gerichtshof eine mehrheit durch die
besetzung durch donald trump und
insofern ist das eine losing strategy
mit tram zu gehen und ich denke dass da
auch viele drüber nachdenken werden also
wie sie aus dieser zwickmühle wieder
rauskommen die aktualität von trump
einerseits und andererseits aber eben
auch die probleme die er ihnen
drei tage der freund jetzt würde ich mal
ganz klar widersprechen präsidenten
also es ist ganz selten dass ein
präsident die partei des präsidenten so
eine schmale mehrheit hat in beiden
kammern des kongresses also dass eine
hauchdünne mehr also eher ungewöhnlich
dann die wahlen der zweiten reihe die
gouverneurs wahlen sind für die
demokraten alles anderes gut gelaufen
gut für die republikaner in den state
heraus es ist für die republikaner gut
gelaufen also ich sehe das ganz anders
dass das eine ganz große niederlage war
natürlich haben sie formal recht es ist
jetzt ein demokrat im weißen haus aber
mit einer hauchdünnen mehrheit die
eigentlich faktisch gar keine mehrheit
ist also joe biden wird äußerst bedacht
seien dort nicht auf konfrontation zu
gehen sondern versuchen ein park wie der
amerikaner sagt quick wins zu machen
eine gesetzesvorlage vorzulegen die
parteiübergreifend funktioniert und dann
wird man sehen ob er auch eine
programmatische antwort hat auf die 74
millionen samt wähler also das ist
keinesfalls ein klarer sieg gewesen die
sie ist versuchen hier darzustellen
losing strategy haben sie gesagt aber
die frage ist ja was bedeutet das für
die für seine ganzen anhänger frau klein
ist es kann es nicht auch bedeuten wenn
jetzt dieses das überhaupt dieses
verfahren jetzt läuft diese debatte
darüber dass es gerade die anhänger von
cramm noch mal besonders
zusammenschweißt und besonders stärkt
eigentlich etwas ganz anderes ist als
das was die demokraten gerne möchten ja
ich glaube dass es eher die gefahr da
eher auf seiten der amerikaner legten es
ist zum einen so dass auch die anwälte
die jetzt gerade da eröffnungsreden
halten die haben sich ja zum beispiel
ganz klar distanziert von dieser gewalt
von diesem mob haben das auch so benannt
haben nur immer betont dass donald trump
damit nichts zu tun hat das ist etwas
ganz anderes als donald trump dennoch an
dem tag selbst gesagt hat wir lieben
euch ihr seid patrioten seid stolz auf
diesen tag also da gibt es eindeutig
deutliche distanzierung und das wird man
auch sehen jetzt im prozess da werden
sich glaube ich auch viele republikaner
von diesen anhänger dort gewalttätig
geworden sind auf jeden fall
distanzieren
und dann ist es so tatsächlich sind die
anhänger der republikanischen partei in
sich genauso gespalten wie die
politische führung wir haben direkt nach
dem 6 januar
mit anhängern von donald trump
gesprochen ganz normalen menschen die
auf dem land leben
und die waren total erzürnt über
jemanden wie mitch mcconnell der aus
ihrer sicht jetzt auch ein verräter ist
und die sagen in zwei jahren wenn wir
damit ganz vielen also in den nächsten
jahren ganz vielen leuten antreten und
nicht irgendwelche scheinen republikaner
sondern trump republikaner also auch
innerhalb der anhängerschaft der
republikanischen partei ist diese
spaltung und das glaube ich wird jetzt
durch diesen durch dieses verfahren
durch die debatten die dort geführt
werden sicher auch noch mal angeheizt
aber klar natürlich kann donald trump
können sich die amerikaner auch immer
noch diese opferrolle stellen aber der
schaden innerhalb der eigenen
anhängerschaft ist glaube ich größer als
der nutzen
also wäre es denn konsequenter
kirschbaum man sagen würde man trump
gründet eine neue partei und die
republikaner die gemäßigten republikaner
machen das wieder ohne donald trump es
gibt solche gerüchte aber alle wissen in
den usa seien holzweg es gibt keine
partei system wie in deutschland
die world all die kandidaten haben so
gut wie keine chancen den usa dass wir
ein geschenk für die demokraten über
dieses tun aber vielleicht wird sich
abspalten seine eigene partei gründen
aber er würde ja nichts los wäre oder
dafür erscheinen gerne an der macht da
vielleicht will sie nur golf spielen
vielleicht wurde nur ein bisschen was
ausfüllt und jetzt und jetzt geht er
doch im ruhestand aber die spannendste
frage für mich ist der traum für immer
das qualifiziert sein als präsident und
dafür braucht er brauchen die demokraten
keine 17 republikaner die banken gar
keine republikaner und ob es zu dieser
zweite stimmen kommt es auch nicht ganz
klar es gibt geteilte meinungen
verfassungsexperte ob die das trotzdem
machen können und ob sie das vielleicht
in zwei drei monaten machen können aber
es gibt ich glaube die märkte losgelöst
von dem verfahren damit wir es verstehen
weil das ja das ist ein zweiter frage
und es gibt verfassungsexperte kommen
aus den löchern in den usa jetzt die
amerikaner wenn sowas belehrt von
experten poly control die verfassung was
die leute damals das geschrieben was die
gemeint haben und es ist ein wirklich
ein lehrstück jetzt wir lernen eine
menge über die die verfassung und was
möglich ist und aber wenn das opfer
woher das ist das was das
amtsenthebungsverfahren richtig läuft
aber dafür braucht man als zwei drittel
mehr
und dann ist die andere frage die man
entscheiden muss kann er noch mal ein
mandat bekommen eine hand bekommen
genauer für immer gesperrt ist ist das
für europa auch eine große wichtige
nachrichten für die welt ist eine ganze
marktbewegende nachrichten sozusagen man
schon für immer und ewig gesperrt wird
der freund das glauben sie dass das was
das bedeuten würde oder oder was welche
konsequenzen könnte das noch alles sein
bezüglich war es jetzt also wenn jetzt
wenn jetzt wirklich gesperrt würde gäbe
es eine andere möglichkeit wie man dann
mit mit damit umgeht was das für ihn
also ist es jemand der sich dann aber
zurück zieht es geht ja nicht anders
oder der jemand anders dann unterstützt
also wir können ja alle trump schwer
hinter die stirn schauen das haben wir
nun gelernt letzten vier jahre
aber kaum ist ja erst mal politisch
nicht kann ich aktiv werden so oder so
weil wir jetzt erstmal zwei jahre lang
den kongress haben nächstes jahr sind
dann die zwischenwahlen im november der
wahlkampf wird in 15 bis 17 monaten
losgehen darf ich wirtschaft so oder so
keine rolle spielen er will ja da wenn
überhaupt aufs weiße haus gehen da steht
man zwar jetzt in 18 monaten nicht zur
wahl an
dh dann werden ganz anderer vorgang da
wird es spannend sein zu beobachten wer
wird dann kandidieren für die
republikanische partei in dem senat und
vor allen dingen auch im
repräsentantenhaus sind das dann wieder
die pisten die in den vorwahlen den
anderen die rang ablaufen innerhalb der
partei oder wird es nicht sein das ist
eine erste richtungsentscheidung und
dann wird man sehen hat die partei sie
emanzipiert von donald trump oder hat
sie es nicht abseits aller juristischen
prozess vonstatten gehen
frage was erwarten sie denn von donald
trump wird das wäre das sinnvoll wenn er
eine partei auf machen würde warum hat
ja schon richtig gesagt das wahlsystem
würde das sehr schwer für ihn machen
dann mehrheiten zu gewinnen und eigene
fernsehsender würde dass man das wäre
vielleicht ein weg den er einschlagen
könnte um eben auch eine plattform zu
haben das ist natürlich nicht das weiße
haus aber darüber wird ja auch schon
spekuliert nicht dass er einen eigenen
sender oder eine eigene sendung
einrichte weil er hat ja immer er kriegt
ja immer noch ziemlich viel geld an
spenden
ja na ja er hat erst mal eine gefüllte
kriegskasse dadurch dass er ja die wahl
schunk immer noch wieder behauptet hat
und dafür gelder eingeworben hat um
diese gefälschte wahl wieder rückgängig
zu machen
das hat sich ja erledigt jetzt ist joe
biden im amt aber das geld hat er und er
hat auch nach wie vor sponsoren also er
kann schon über gelder verfügen um
vielleicht nicht nur für sich selber
sondern auch seine kinder nach vorne zu
bringen nicht also ivanka trump von der
wir wissen dass sie gerne in florida
senatorin werden möchte oder auch sein
sohn donald junior eric das sind alles
persönlichkeiten die auch politisch
ambitionen haben und es kann auch sein
dass er eben diese reihe dann fördert ok
dass wir auch noch mal interessant weil
sie den wahlbetrug gerade angesprochen
haben frau klein ist es noch ein thema
samt anhänger glauben ja immer noch
glaube ich zu zwei dritteln dass die
wahl gefälscht ist ist das noch was was
diskutiert wird oder gibt es da ein
bisschen mehr frieden sei die beiden
jetzt ins weiße haus eingezogen ist das
kommt davon wie man frieden definiert
das ist vielleicht nichts was jetzt
offen diskutiert wird aber das ist etwas
wo beide seiten immer noch auf ihren
standpunkten waren also es gibt immer
noch viele menschen im land die glauben
dass das eine gestohlene wahl war die
die beiden für einen legitimen
präsidenten halten und die rücken davon
auch nicht ab die hatten noch ein
bisschen hoffnung als wir mit denen kurz
nach dem 6 januar sprachen dass trump
irgend ein ass aus dem ärmel ziehen wird
das hat er nicht gehabt er ist aus dem
weißen haus ausgezogen ist eingezogen
aber das hält er seine anhänger nicht
davon ab weiter zu glauben dass job eine
legitime präsident ist und da wird
glaube ich jetzt viel darauf ankommen
es gibt menschen die wird so beiden
überzeugen können aber ich glaube bei
ein paar der wählern dann wird es
wahrscheinlich darauf ankommen wie gut
er jetzt tatsächlich wirklich
erleichterungen deren leben ermöglicht
wie zum beispiel die korona pandemie
bekämpft ob er es schafft dass da
schnell viele menschen geimpft sind wir
seien corinna hilfspaket durch durch den
kongress bringt um menschen dann
tatsächlich auch geld in die taschen zu
geben also das sind schon sachen die er
nach vorantreibt die sehr schlau sind
weil sie einen direkten einfluss auf das
leben vieler menschen haben und das ist
vielleicht eine möglichkeit wie er ein
paar der republik
anhänger doch zumindest dazu bewegen
könnte zu sagen okay das ist nicht mein
präsident aber der macht das ganz gut
und dann wird es immer einen kern geben
den er damit nicht erreichen wird egal
was er tut
das ist ja das programm mit dem er so
angetreten dass dieses land zu heilen
darüber sprach er sehr viel zu 1
herr kirschbaum er hat jetzt gesagt lass
mal den senat seine arbeit machen also
im moment erhält er sich da extrem
zurück gerade was das
amtsenthebungsverfahren jetzt betrifft
dass er das nicht besonders kommentiert
ja das 36 jahre lang senator will dass
das alter selbst entscheidet natürlich
ich glaube beiden hätte es lieber wenn
es kein amtsenthebungsverfahren gegeben
hätte er lieber mit seinen namen
nominees für die kabinett durchdringen
könnte es gab nur sechs oder sieben sind
bisher genehmigt und er hat lieber sein
legislativ programm an angekurbelt
gleich losgelegt
aber wenn es nur eine woche jetzt dauert
und wahrscheinlich wird es nur eine
woche kann beiden damit leben aber
beiden will beiden weiß dass die uhr
läuft hatten und zwei jahren zeit bis
mit terminals kommen will sofern möglich
machen wir so viel machen wie möglich
und die pandemie ist das große thema
nummer eins als überlagert alles und er
will schnell erfolge da haben das sind
viele mehr amerikaner geimpft als in
deutschland und beiden weiß wenn er
nicht erfolg hat ist in zwei jahren dann
ist die mehrheit weg da hat das mit
obama erlebt obama nur zwei jahre die
mehrheit und beiden wir diese fehler war
es beiden beiden wo die vier levels
obama vermeiden
aber wenn das so ist warum hat er denn
dann ja nicht stärker davon abgeraten
den seiner parteien das ganze verfahren
überhaupt ja der präsident der präsident
hat nicht so viel macht wie manche
denken der kongress hat die macht und
der kongress will das machen und beiden
weiß dass wir das wäre töricht
einzumischen und er hatte die finger
abgebissen bekommen wenn er sagt das
nicht
er hat wahrscheinlich hinter der bühne
gesagt muss das sein aber ich glaube
sagt ja das muss sein weil das ist genau
das argument was viel selber machen wenn
das jetzt nicht ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren prozess verdient
hätte wandel
ja das ist das ja aber trotzdem haben
die frage von namco wie sehr kann es
denn einen demokraten schaden und auch
der der der dem start von joe biden der
jetzt loslegen
es ist jetzt wirklich eine frage wie
lange dauert das verfahren und wenn es
tatsächlich ende nächster woche schon zu
ende geht glaube ich hat beiden gute
chancen sein arbeitsprogramm dann auch
weiter zügig durchzuziehen
er hat ja schon ein scharfes tempo
vorgelegt nicht aber viele seiner
entscheidung waren erstmal über
präsidentielle erlasse er muss ja jetzt
auch den gesetzgebungsprozess in
wichtigen bereichen anschieben zu ende
bringen und hat für sich in anspruch
genommen auch mit den republikanern zu
arbeiten in der gesetzgebung und das
muss man jetzt sehen dass er das auch
wirklich hinkriegt also von daher denke
ich hänge vieles davon ab wie schnell
dieses verfahren auch beendet werden
kann wie immer ist dann ausgeht dass die
demokraten ist machen müssen glaube ich
ist gar keine frage
denn man will ja auch durch dieses
verfahren sicher stellen dass also
wahrheit wahrheit bleibt und eine lüge
über die wahlen zb nicht bestand hat und
dass es auch grenzen gibt in der
demokratie die man nicht überschreiten
darf und das kapitol zu besetzen ist so
eine kleine ja der mehrheitsfraktionen
demokraten hat heute die republikaner
aufgefordert die schwere der vergehen zu
verstehen die beweislage zu würdigen hat
so richtig appelliert an die
republikaner kathi vorwürfe sind eben
sehr sehr ernst herr freund hoffen sie
dass es den demokraten schadet dieses
verfahren also hoffen will ich gar nicht
mehr sagen die frage ist gestellt beiden
sich auf herrn hirschmann hat sehr schön
gesagt er hat er nicht viel einfluss
drauf und ich kann auch nicht gelegen
sein dass die sache sehr konfrontativ
geführt wird denn die amerikaner eins
ums andere mal bei dem
gesetzgebungsverfahren brauchen seine
mehrheit ist sehr dünn chef weise darauf
hin dass an der regierung obama einige
sätze der eigenen demokratischen partei
vom kongress abgeschmettert worden sind
und das trotz der großen mehrheit
und zwar auch die administration obama
schon mal als auch erwähnt die die
größte schlappe bei den zwischenwahlen
erlebt hat seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
also das muss man alles beachten und das
trotz durchgesetzt der gesundheitsreform
das heißt da gibt es viele
eventualitäten da muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein ich glaube man ist nicht
gut daran dass die demokratische partei
jetzt hier eine politik macht eine
große bühne ein großes fass aufmacht und
dann wenn das politische verfahren ins
leere läuft hat man dann die politischen
schaden im tagesgeschäft also das ist
ein ganz schmaler grat und man wird sich
genau überlegen müssen wie weit man den
bogen das spannende
da ist der präsident aber auch so ein
bisschen allein auf sich gestellt gibt
auch kräfte im kongress auch vor dem
progressiven die unbedingt dieses
verfahren wollen
und die sind auch nicht zu stoppen also
ich glaube da ist man nicht ganz herr
des geschehens auch frau klein wie
beurteilen sie das diese an dieser
wunsch von beiden dieses land zu einen
und dann auf der anderen seite jetzt so
ein verfahren zu haben was ja noch mal
ganz klar die position so deutlich macht
also wie kann man da vorangehen was
erwarten sie da auch in der politischen
auseinandersetzung weiter und ich glaube
das was eben gesagt wurde es richtig die
demokraten sind fest davon überzeugt
dass sie nach diesen ereignissen am
sechsten januar nicht einfach zur
tagesordnung übergehen können dass man
das dem präsidenten nicht durchgehen
lassen kann und dieses verfahren hat ja
für die demokraten noch einen zweiten
charme es wird am ende eine namentliche
abstimmung sein das heißt jeder auch
jeder republikanische senator wird mit
seinem namen abstimmen müssen verurteilt
er oder sie donald trump oder nicht was
das motiv der einigkeit anbetrifft damit
argumentieren jetzt ja vor allen dingen
die amerikaner der die republikaner die
sagen wenn die demokraten das weiter
voranbringen dann verstoßen sie gegen
diese einigkeit aber die haben umgekehrt
ja auch jede gelegenheit an einem
gemeinsamen politischen projekt
mitzuarbeiten jenseits dieses
impeachment es liegt dass gruner
hilfspaket auf den tisch 1,9 milliarden
mit hilfe direkter hilfe für viele
menschen die gerade unternehmen massiv
leiden und da haben die amerikaner ja
auch die möglichkeit gemeinsam am strang
zu ziehen und das ist das worauf
präsident biden sich jetzt konzentrieren
möchte aber ich sehe das auch so beide
seiten haben kein großes interesse daran
dieses impeachment verfahren besonders
lange zu betreiben dann ist man damit
vielleicht nächste woche durch und dann
kann man sich diesen konkreten
politischen projekten widmen
ok dann hätte man könnte man einen punkt
machen erklärt bank rechnen sie noch mit
einer überraschung weil die meisten
rechnen damit dass es eben nicht so
einer zwei drittel mehrheit kommt es
gebe ja noch diesen trick das ist bei
dem impetus verfahren ist ja so dass
zwei drittel der senatoren die im raum
an
sind müssen ja dann stimmen also wenn
die jetzt einfach rausgehen also gibt es
da noch möglichkeiten dass man sagt ja
es wird vielleicht auch noch anders
ausgehen als die meisten erwarten
ich glaube nicht dass 17 republikaner
von der stange gehen wird vielleicht
fünf oder sieben oder acht sein
das war vielleicht eine sieg für die
demokraten
man darf auch nicht vergessen vor einem
jahr schon kam aus den im pitch bend
verfahren gestärkt daraus vor dem
jahrzehnt unschlagbar aber zusammen ist
zusammengebrochen wollen in den senat
diese ukraine verfahren und schon vor
dem china der große sieger die
wirtschaft lief ganz gut bevor kommune
die demokraten wollen ein haufen
scherbenhaufen
diese 3 mio es schien ganz gut
verschoben vielleicht ist das auch was
passieren könnte ist schon kommt aus
dieser verfahren nächste woche gestärkt
plötzlich ist kommt dann schnell hat so
ein großes problem wie jetzt keine
ahnung aber das 17 republikaner von der
stange gehen und mit den demokraten
während es eher unwahrscheinlich aber
würdig sind ihrem eid verpflichtet und
vielleicht wird es ein paar
überraschungen geben und den
republikaner die dann doch mit
stimmengewinn sie noch mit
überraschungen rechnen
also im letzten jahr im ersten
amtsenthebungsverfahren hat nur ein
einziger republikaner mit den demokraten
gestimmt
mitt romney und in diesem verfahren
finde ich ganz interessant das immerhin
zehn republikaner im abgeordnetenhaus
für das engagement verfahren bestimmt
haben und auch im senat also klar wir
haben einige namen sind jetzt schon
genannt einige statements liegen auch
schon vor aber ich würde es auch für
sehr unwahrscheinlich halten dass diese
hürde von 17 stimmen bei den
republikanern genommen wird also
insofern denn das dann ist dann die
folge tatsächlich das trump danach
eigentlich gestärkt raus kommt war das
würde ja heißen
man kann also eine
entwicklung wie die am sechsten januar
mit diesem dramatischen sturm auf dem
capitol mit sieben toten mit soviel
verletzten dass das so durchgehen kann
nein ich denke nicht dass er gestärkt
daraus hervorgehen kann weil zum einen
festgestellt wird und mit der abstimmung
rechnen wir heute dass auch der
präsident sich also dass
rechenschaftspflichtig ist und sich
nicht alles leisten kann in den letzten
namens seit tagen und das zweite ist
also was da jetzt auch an ich sag mal so
beweisen der demokraten auf den tisch
gelegt werden wird das ist schon
bedrückend das sind ganz ganz schwierige
bilder da ist auch material dabei dass
wir noch nicht gesehen haben und das ist
eine sehr beschämende situation finde
ich also ich denke nicht dass man da
einfach zur tagesordnung übergehen kann
und kann sagen ja also das damit hat
schon gar nichts zu tun ich glaube schon
dass er dadurch
ja doch ein stück weit auch beschädigt
wird in denen in den augen derjenigen
die seiner glühenden anhänger sind
natürlich nicht aber die wird die wird
man eh nicht überzeugen
aber ich denke nicht dass er daraus
gestärkt hervorgehen wird
herr freund wie sehen sie was kann wie
sehr kann dieses verfahren donald trump
stärken also und auch eine sehr
radikalen flügel der partei letztendlich
also vielleicht etwas grundsätzliches
der senat ist kein gericht und wird es
auch nicht sein
der senat muss im gegensatz zu einem
gericht das recht von unrecht rennen
muss und auch dann ahnt muss schaut der
senat auch politisch nach vorne und sagt
was bringt etwas leben nützt es dem
nutzer ist nichts macht es überhaupt
sinn
inwieweit durch so ein bisschen
widersprechen wollen dass das dass man
hier sagt argumentiert bis hierhin ich
weiter man muss das benennen
also es ist immer auch eine politische
botschaft immer auch ein ausblick nach
vorne
die zweite sache ist natürlich es wird
auf den ton darauf ankommen ist es ein
freispruch erster klasse oder ist es nur
ein nicht impeachment auch das wird sich
den nächsten tagen zeigen inwieweit dort
je fakten auf den tisch gelegt werden
wie weit das land in der politischen
diskussion
was ist etwas wäre dann ein freispruch
erster klasse
der fall wird erst der klasse wäre wenn
wenige republikaner
der kirschbaum richtig sagt von der
stange gehen und zum zweiten wenn die
argumentationsbasis oder wie die neuen
fakten die angeblich kommen sollen auf
die wir alle warten dann doch nicht so
neu sind wie ist zu glauben scheint also
dass werden freispruch erster klasse 2
der klasse wäre es geht in der tat acht
republikaner noch mehr gehen von der
stange und es kommt doch sachen zum
tragen also die dann auch die meisten
republikaner zu denken geben würde
da muss man abwarten inwieweit es den
präsidenten nutzt oder schadet wenn sie
mit stimmen könnten was würden sie denn
tun also nach der jetzigen aktenlage
mögen würde ich das was präsidenten
gemacht hat wirklich verurteilen aber
ich würde sagen es würde nicht zu einem
amtsenthebungsverfahren lang dazu bedarf
schon ein bisschen mehr
sie würden dann nicht dafür stimmen wird
nicht dafür dann okay aus politischen
gründen
frau klein was was denken sie ist dass
in der diskussion die da geführt wird
dass man sagt ja eigentlich stärkt
stärken wird haben was erwarten sie wird
es eine stärkung geben und werden wir
sozusagen herrn trump wiedersehen als
jemand der weder viel aktiver dann sich
einmischt das weiß ich nicht ich würde
den blick auch nicht nur auf tram
brächten den moment sondern für mich
wird interessant sein zu sehen wie sich
die republikanischen senatoren verhalten
wie sie auch argumentieren und was das
dann wiederum bei der basis macht weil
diese position gerade zu sagen das war
alles nicht in ordnung aber das reicht
nicht um den patch mensch ist ja auch
schon eine kritik an donald trump ist ja
auch schon etwas was bei der
republikanischen basis zumindest bei den
richtigen trump anhängern gefährlich ist
also dass die die republikanischen
senatoren haben da wenn sie auftreten
eine wirklich schwierige aufgabe wenn
sie versuchen wollen einerseits das was
dort passiert ist zu verurteilen das als
etwas verurteilung würdig und
andererseits aber donald trump nicht im
geringsten an den karren zu fahren
nichts zu kritisieren weil das eben
seine basis verändern könnte die haben
da wirklichen schweren stand und das
finde ich nachher spannend zu sehen wenn
dann dieses ganze verfahren rum s was
das dann bei der basis macht
stimmungstechnisch und ob dann viele
dieser senatoren dann plötzlich auch für
die alle verräter sind darum die
wirklichen schwierige aufgabe und das
wird sich in den nächsten wochen traf
anzusehen und es ist ja auch nicht
jemand anderes da der sozusagen diese
rolle von donald trump übernehmen könnte
er kirchmann gibt es da irgendein jemand
starkes in der partei wo man sagt der
könnte sozusagen auch die auch die
republikanischen anhänger befrieden nein
noch nicht nicht in der groß wie
deutschland aber es gibt natürlich leute
mit ambitionen die den kandidat cruz
kommt der name kommt wieder der welt
wieder kandidat werden und setzen und
eine braskem mario ruby rubacuori wo und
freude wie wir das in aufnahmen die
wahrscheinlich wieder kandidieren die
werden hoffentlich dass die hoffen dass
trump ruhig bleibt und schon
verschwindet das ist die hoffnung aber
ich wusste vorher ist zu sagen ich
stimme voll amt wird sie zwar gesagt hat
trump hat in den vier jahren was seit
hundert jahren passiert nicht passiert
ist hat das weiße haus verloren
verloren uns den madrilenen in vier
jahren ist das seit 100 jahren ist
passiert dass eine partei die mehrheit
in alle drei hatten alle drei verloren
deswegen die republikaner werden sich in
sich hinein gehen und gucken was haben
wir alles verloren was haben wir alles
schief weil es zu seine schief gelaufen
die haben eine große niederlage im
november leiten und dann im januar als
die die zwei sitze in georgia that on
habe die republikaner haben eine
schwierige situation jetzt die haben
haushoch jetzt führen obwohl es eine
dünne mehrheit ist aber trotzdem alle
drei jailbreak superliga in vier jahren
gab es erst vor eine million man auch
sagen dann lassen wir sie lassen wir das
lieber alles so in ruhe und die haben
genug probleme mit sich selber und wir
machen sie mich was aus demokratischer
sicht wir machen sie nicht noch stärker
in dem wir jetzt dauernd wieder über der
klamm prägen nein aber wackelt geht das
ganz schnelles und dynamisches prozess
die republikaner bilden zwei jahren
wieder führen die figuren haben die
leute werden die obama ganz schnell
auftauchen ich bin überzeugt dass es
wird nicht lange dauern bevor wir starke
republikanische kandidaten sehen und die
und es gibt eine große mehrheit eine
große anteil der amerikaner die
konservative denken konstruktiv ticken
die verfassung wie kannst du so prim
kult die denken daran die denken an an
waffen und so es gibt eine einer 40
prozent anteil der aktiven im
republikanisch wäre nur die die wahl nur
auf den richtigen kandidaten die die
hoffen dass der kommt und es wird eine
kommen bin ich überzeugt ok auf was
hoffen sie denn herr freund für ihre
partei ich muss ein bisschen schmunzeln
wenn ich höre dass gegen graben in der
republikanischen partei
also ich glaube den gibt es nicht recht
politisch den gibt es im tonfall den
gibt es in der absolutistischen
auftretens weise aber in puncto
diskussion um handel diskussion um china
diskussion um innere sicherheit
ich glaube da ist die republikanische
partei vollkommen homogenen da sehe ich
bei der demokratischen partei eine viel
größere spanne von links nach rechts
also dass ich wünsche mir vor allen
dingen dass jetzt da kommt ja nicht mehr
im amt ist jetzt eine opposition politik
gemacht wird auch konsens politik und
man noch klare kante zeigt aber noch mal
es ist an den präsidenten zur zeit zu
zeigen ob er bereit ist an einer
zusammenarbeit oder ob er versucht seine
sache durchzuziehen
das wird sehr spannend sein ob sie
kopton link gesetze auf den weg zu
bringen wie auch die mehrheit der
demokratischen partei findet und da ist
das wichtigste ja natürlich die korona
pandemie die wie man damit umgeht frau
klein da machen wir noch mal konkret was
auf was müssen wir jetzt noch diese
woche warten heute abend warten wir noch
auf die diese erste abstimmung da sehen
sie übrigens auch den ganzen abend
natürlich weiter bei phoenix und auf was
müssen wir uns einstellen die nächsten
tage wer also diese woche wird der im
prozess dass ich einen großen teil der
arbeit des senates beanspruchen es gab
mal die diskussion ob sie haben samstag
aussetzenden tag ist wenn sie nicht tun
sie werden bis samstag inklusive durch
verhandelte am montag das ist hier ein
öffentlicher feiertag werden sie
trotzdem wieder weitermachen das ist
jetzt erstmal das beherrschende thema
aber wie schon mehrfach an verschiedenen
stellen gesagt beide seiten haben großes
interesse daran dass kurz zu halten und
dann kann es mit den politischen
vorhaben weiter gehen ein paar sachen
sind schon auf den weg gebracht der
nächste große brocken sozusagen ist dann
tatsächlich das corona hilfspaket
und da wird man sehen müssen ob die
beiden das mit stehen republikaner im
konsens in bekommt oder ob er das auf
einem umweg mit der eigenen partei
ziemlich sind teilen alleine umsetzen
und vor allem kommt wenn es diese
abstimmung geht darüber dass beiden kein
mandat mehr haben kann was bedeutet das
eigentlich konkret das wäre glaube ich
tatsächlich ein warnsignal auch an viele
andere die mit rechts populistischen
mitteln versuchen politik zu machen und
auch keine scheu haben nach rechts offen
zu sein oder gewalt sozusagen auch zu
gut zu heißen zu tolerieren
also das ist ja so weit ich weiß bis
land noch nicht vorgekommen in der
amerikanischen geschichte
dadurch dass ich kandidieren er hatte
auch keinen kann gern ein öffentliches
jahr mit also jetzt nicht nur für die
präsidentschaft sondern überhaupt kein
öffentliches amt mehr bekleiden und das
ist schon die ärmste wo hätte er noch
mitarbeitern
nein nein also ich meine ob sich das
jetzt auf seine altersversorgung
auswirkt weiß ich nicht da haben wir
auch keine präzedenzfälle aber also das
ist schon ein politisch sehr hartes
urteil wäre das wenn es dann zu werben
das gab möglichen bürgerkrieg ein
kriegsminister wo das passiert ist der
es nachträglich im pitch wurden nachdem
ihr zurückgetreten herr billen habe er
genau weiß das schon passiert und was
und das was hieße da heißt das dann dass
man da dürften die schmiede mindeste der
darf derweil personen an gerade dann in
der politik
es ist passiert es gibt eine
vorgeschichte für was passieren könnte
okay aber wir sind gespannt erfreuen und
mit was rechnen sie ganz kurz zum
schluss was recht wenn sie zum ende der
woche
ich glaube das geht aus wie das
hornberger schießen
am ende des tages wird eine abstimmung
geben die wird eine einfache mehrheit
finden aber eben keine zwei drittel
mehrheit und ich glaube danach richten
sich auf das tagesgeschäft konzentrieren
müssen es war man hat einfach mal
akzente gesetzt hat mal zähne gezeigt
glaube dass war das wichtigste eine
gewisse symbolpolitik
aber ich glaube politisch wird sich doch
nicht wie bewegen aber auch eigentlich
sowie politik läuft oder so sollte man
das könnte man zusammenfassen
ok vielen dank also vielen dank frau
klein nachforschungen sie beobachten ist
natürlich auch weiter vielen dank herr
freund jan der christbaum und frau lemke
und wir beobachten dass natürlich auch
weiter bei phoenix für sie den ganzen
abend und jetzt macht erstmal meine
kollegin weit
im system phoenix der tag julia grimm
ist weil sie da bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]
doku verpasst schade
sie finden zahlreiche dokumentationen
die wichtigsten ereignisse und unsere
gespräche unter phoenix de phoenix der
tag
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zu unserer
spätausgabe für nix der tag den ganzen
abend schon schauen wir in die usa nach
washington